[Music]
hello my name is Julian poo and I am
your substitute teacher for today I am
replacing National Master uh Ralph tan
and um our subject is going to be the
opening principles so when you first
start a game of chess it might not be
completely obvious um what it is uh you
should be doing um there are three
positive principles and there are three
negative principles at least that's the
way um that I was taught so and
generally in the opening um it is said
that you should control the center
generally with pawns and also with
pieces uh you should try to develop your
pieces and you should
Castle um those are the three positive
principles the negative principles are
uh things you should not be doing you
should not move your queen out too early
you shouldn't move the same piece twice
and you shouldn't make too many pawn
moves now all of those principes
um basically boil down to don't waste
time in the opening now in chess there's
an exception to every rule but generally
speaking when you're first starting out
try not to waste too much time in the
opening um the first game I'm going to
show you is uh probably the most
reviewed game uh ever in chess it
borders on cliche but uh it's so cliche
a friend of mine told me that uh it's
the chess equivalent of putting on a
movie when you're uh teaching a chess
lesson but I'm The Substitute Teacher so
I get to put on a movie during the chess
lesson um this is a game played between
this is the Opera game uh White played
Pawn E4 Pawn E5 Knight F3 D6 D4 and
black plays this move Bishop to G4 so so
far both sides have kind of done a good
job controlling the center white has put
two Pawns in the center black has
reinforced the center with the D Pawn um
but now black has played this move
Bishop to G4 um so the idea of Bishop G4
is if I were to capture the pawn on E5
well black is going to remove the
defender of the E5 Pawn by playing
Bishop takes
F3 Queen takes F3 and then Pawn takes E5
but can anybody identify what the issue
with Black's last two moves
were what mistake has black made what
mistake has black
made it violates the opening
principles
somebody says I look like fbby that's
true he moved the piece twice and lost
the bishop pair yeah so black played the
move Bishop from C8 to G4 and then
Bishop from G4 to F3 and white has only
moveed this piece once so you've
essentially traded a piece that has
moved twice for a piece that's moved
once um
and also the position is uh slightly
more open than a typical position
because a pair of Pawns have already
been traded so Bishops should be
slightly favored here as well um you
will notice that on the starting
position uh what well white has
developed this this piece for free and
it's also his turn so white is up two
moves essentially for nothing okay if
you were to continue to try to play uh
for white what would you guys like to
do
MH uh where which Square in
particular
C well C6 is not possible right
not two yeah C4 yeah I agree Bishop C4
is a really good move um so like let's
pretend black does nothing say he plays
the move Pawn A5 which moves a Pawn on
the side does not control the center
doesn't develop a piece doesn't help
black in any way
whatsoever
so what would you do here with white
what was the point of your move so I
could Castle so you could Castle yeah so
that's a good idea generally in the
opening but we have something like very
specific that we can do here uh Queen
all the way up checkm yeah Queen of7
Checkmate GG so uh Bishop C4 makes a
massive threat uh black decides to
defend against this threat with Knight
to
F6 uh White in this position uh plays
the move Queen to B3 which attacks F7
and
B7 um and black plays the move Queen E7
uh which has the intention of Defending
F7 and um if you were to move your queen
to a different square like let's say D7
for instance then after Queen B7 your
Rook is is attacked and trapped Queen C6
doesn't help you uh it is White's play
and win after Queen to C6 what would you
like to
do okay you probably have several wins
but one is better than all the others
Bishop to C4 is incorrect the bishop is
on C4 unless I spread the
time
yeah Queen C8 probably wins too but you
have something that's just much
cleaner so you will notice that this
King and this queen are along the same
diagonal right which means that they are
going to so if I have a piece that you
know moves diagonally maybe there's a
way I can take advantage of
that where up the left here yeah Bishop
B5 so the bishop is pinning the queen to
the king and uh White has won the game
okay
so um you can't move your queen to a
random Square now for what it's worth
black should probably play a move like
Bishop D6 and then react differently
depending upon how white plays but uh
Queen E7 was played such that if you
play the move Queen takes B7 then white
gets to play the move Queen to B4 now
there's nothing wrong with this position
for white in fact uh White is
objectively probably winning here
because U because of his good opening
play we have netted a pawn in exchange
for our developments and we have two
Bishops and the end game is uh more than
just a little Pleasant for white white
might even be objectively winning there
um so after the move Queen E7 white in
the game instead decided to play Knight
to C3 uh saying okay I I don't take your
Pawn but Queen E7 sure it's sort of
defends against Queen takes B7 but it
slows down your development right in in
order for you to develop your dark squar
Bishop now you're going to have to move
your queen out of the way and then move
your bishop or you're going to have to
fing K the bishop on this side of the
board so Queen E7 is not um uh is not
super helpful for Black's development
black played the move Pawn to
C6 um what move would you guys like to
play here with
white in theme with our opening
principles
yeah where where would just up against
the Knight yeah that's right Bishop to
G5 this is um doing two things we are
developing a piece and we are also
making sure this Knight can't move right
so if if the Knight were to move away
from the F6 Square then the E7 sorry
then Bishop would capture the queen on7
um so the Knight flat out can't move
this is really awkward for black to deal
with um if black plays like some normal
it's actually really hard to come up
with some normal move for black like uh
something like G6 fails to Bishop F6 and
queen B7 The Rook is again trapped on A8
uh so if you play Knight D7 I play the
move Queen B7 because you have uh gotten
rid of the defense over the B7 Pawn so
black instead decided to lash out with
the move Pawn to B5 which in principle
uh should be a pretty good decision um
white decided in the game to sacrifice
their Knights because uh concretely um
Paul morphe was a good player and
calculated ahead and saw that he was
winning his his uh material back but
also also intuitively like you know that
if if the King goes to d8 like obviously
in the opening we want to be castling
right the king's all open and exposed
he's very likely to get checkmated um a
concrete variation you might calculate
would be something like Bishop F6 and
queen D5 although even this was probably
not the best way for white to play um
instead black played the move Knight D7
which is a good move Castle's Queen side
and now I'm going to ask a funny
question what happens at black Castle's
Queen side White's play and
when what would you guys like to do with
Bishop capture the Knight so if you play
Bishop takes D7 then black will play
Rook takes
D7 and it's not entirely clear to me
what your followup is going to be you're
kind of introducing Defenders over to
the queen side
right uh I'll give you a hint it is a
it's checkm in two moves
we have forced mate and two check with
the bishop yeah check with the bishop
King C7
now yeah Queen B7 Checkmate easy King
cannot go to D6 on account of The Rook
being on D1 okay so in this position
after uh Castle's Queen side black did
not play the move castles Queen sight in
response instead he played the move uh
Rook to d8 and here white played the
best move of the game um I will give you
a really stupid plan and I want you to
improve upon that plan white actually
sorry I should ask a question first if
you could pick up this Rook right which
is our um the piece that's doing the
least right it's in the corner not doing
very much this Rook is good this
Bishop's pinning that Knight this
Bishop's pinning the other Knight this
Rook is not doing anything so let's say
you could pick him up and put him
anywhere where would you put that
Rook yeah where E7 E7 well yeah on on an
unoccupied Square I should specify why
did you say E7 instead of E8 if you're
going to cheat cheat
better
horrible so if you could put pick this
guy up and put him anywhere where would
you put him bunch of squares
identical or equivalent in value I
should
say on yeah just put your Rook anywhere
on the D file and uh well black can't
really defend against Rook takes D7 okay
I'm going to give you a stupid plan okay
this is the stupidest plans get I want
to go rookie one rookie two Rook Rook D2
and Rook takes D7 how can you improve
upon that
plan move the other Rook out of the way
yeah so you if you move this Rook first
and then black does you know nothing uh
okay let's make it actually nothing then
Rook D1 and you've improved upon my plan
by a full tempo right so this will take
you three moves instead of two now Paul
morphe figured out what the middleman
the middlemen were in that variation so
he he managed to do it even even faster
Rook D2 Rook D1 though is strictly
speaking improving upon that
plan yes can we with the yes Rook takes
D7 exclam uh so Knight takes loses a
queen queen takes loses a queen king
takes is illegal and bad so Rook takes
is the only move and now we get to play
Rook D1 right so um we have played this
uh this sequence in the most efficient
way possible now black here is losing if
I take on D7 like if you play H6 I take
on D7 Queen takes lose as a queen
obviously Knight takes again lose as a
queen and uh king take King to d8 gets
checkmated so black decided to move his
Queen out of the way right so so now
after Bishop takes which was played in
the game Knight takes there's no Queen
on E7 the bishop uh is not attacking the
queen anymore however uh black blundered
something this is now white to play and
Checkmate in two
moves
twitch chat has got it of course yes
okay of course 1500 who showed up to be
to begin her breakdown sees it Queen B8
takes Rook d8 Checkmate and uh yeah
that's it um notice that at the end of
the game these pieces did not move and
they're all on the back rank doing
absolutely nothing these are referred to
as morphe opponent pieces right uh
because his morphy's opponents are very
famous for not moving their pieces out
and getting uh getting destroyed in this
way so what happened right it seemed
like black didn't do a whole lot wrong
and just got destroyed so um it all
stemmed from this move Bishop to G4 for
what it's worth this position actually
isn't too bad for black after Pawn takes
E5 you can play the move Knight to D7
and kind of play this position like a
Gambit and you um are increasing your
development as black uh in exchange for
material um
the idea though that black had in mind
this game was all right I've trade a
bishop for a knight Bishops and knights
are roughly equivalent in value um Queen
takes Pawn takes everything's the same
what's the big deal but the problem is
white has two moves for free and
immediately is gener uh generating an
initiative and then white just played
the most efficient sequence of moves uh
to follow afterwards right C3 C6 Bishop
G5 um castling King site again would be
fine but um Bishop G5 is just the most
efficient way to get your pieces into
the game so Pawn B5 Knight B5 and so on
so everybody makes fun of you know
morphe's opponents uh for losing quickly
but uh um PE you know uh people even of
a very high level still make make this
mistake all the time where they just
forget to develop their pieces during
the game like somehow uh you just think
oh I'm uh I'm good enough to ignore the
opening principles no the opening
principles are always important so
develop your pieces uh control the
center and Castle I'm now going to show
a game that I played um I am playing an
opponent who is rated uh like 2 to10
USCF play the move Pawn to E4 my
opponent played Pawn C5 play Knight F3
Pawn G6 play Pawn to D4 CD and queen
takes D4 now Queen takes D4 here
technically violates an opening
principle because we have moved our
Queen too early but the justification
for this is that the Rook is attacked
and he's going to have to uh deal with
that right so my opponent played the
move Knight to F6 I played Knight to C3
he played Knight to C6 now if I go back
then I have I have just wasted time
right there's no point in me playing
this way so instead I played Queen to A4
which is a more active Square um and
here uh
black really ought to play the move Pawn
to D6 which is what he did if you play a
move like Bishop G7 which seems good
because you're developing a piece well
white can actually take advantage of um
uh of Black's play so how would you guys
play here with white to gain a rather
sizable
Advantage
Knight this Knight where
uh D4 so Knight to D4
um I don't know if that move
loses the B okay so you are so when you
put your knight on this diagonal so this
Bishop's looking over here right so I
always got to ask myself the question if
I can play a move like Knight takes E4
Knight D4 Knight E4 because if you take
me then I take you and if you take me
then I take you um might so yeah
I'm I'm not in love with this move I
think that it just doesn't work right
the end of the sequence this is hanging
this is hanging it's Al also just
trapped now we can force our opponent's
pieces
backwards and strengthen our control
over the
center
ah twitch twitch chat has got it of
course yes can we push the small one in
the middle okay uh yes you may you may
play Pawn to E5 now G4 is controlled by
the queen if you go Knight H5 then G4
and the Knight is trapped and if you go
back well you've I mean you've violated
the opening principles right you've
moved the same piece twice you're
undevelop your pieces white will would
continue with something like Bishop F4
Castle's Queen side and you will notice
that black has developed zero pieces
right and it's about to get destroyed in
the center um Alla morphe um instead my
opponent played the move Pawn D6 which
is a much better move I played E5 and
far far in a way the most common and
best move is Pawn takes E5 uh that is
not what my opponent played my opponent
played play the move Knight to G4 um and
Here If This Were a more advanced class
I would ask I would ask you guys uh to
try to play the best move for white I'll
just tell you what the best move is for
white um I played the move Bishop B5
which is okay it I mean white is still
much better um the best way for white to
play for for what it's worth is Pawn
takes D6 Queen B6 and Knight D5 I did
not figure that out during the game um
just because everything everything like
kind of works out for white but all
right ignoring that that exists Knight
G4 before I play the move Bishop B5 uh
just with the very simple idea that yeah
I'm sacrificing this Pawn but look I
have four pieces developed and my
opponent has this Knight on C6 and
that's that's about it
right um okay now I'll give you a small
positional test this is for black black
is still worse by some margin but you
don't have to lose it's black to play
what would you do with
black I'll flip the board for
convenience don't necessarily understand
the suggestions in
chat uh so I think E6 was suggested but
the issue with a move like Pawn with
Pawn to E6 um is I might attack your
queen I think this is probably probably
what I would do and then if your queen
moves I might play so like you want to
move your queen to a square that defends
the C6 Knight if you go somewhere else I
will take and you know you got you got
forked um shout out to our series get
forked it's my favorite series on
YouTube all right Queen C7 Bishop to
G5 uh and if you go Bishop
G7 uh White's play and
win oh wait actually you have a sick win
you have many wins
but I didn't realize what I put on the
board luckily Paul morphe pointed out
this pattern to
you
I will flip the board again white to
play and
win yes can we capture the horse with
the bishop yeah and then after takes
take the queen nice Queen takes C6 Queen
takes C6 because if you don't take my
queen I will take your queen and
then all right all right Devon Rook da
Check Maiden is the exact same pattern
that you had in in Mor's game um yeah so
E6 I think doesn't work for for that
reason maybe there are other reasons but
in this position it is black to play and
survive who can do it and
why okay so there's a chat has suggested
one of two candidate moves and I I
really think these are the moves you
should be thinking about so um my
opponent played one of these two moves
and the other one and the other one is
correct I won't tell you which one is
which Bishop G7 or Bishop
D7 now which one is correct and
why because those are both developing
moves that serve two different but
important
purposes
to
D7
you're that yeah your queen no protect
yes so you're you're you're definitely
um Bishop D7 definitely serves the
function of protecting
C6
uh okay so there's there's an argument
to be made for Bishop D7
canle Bishop G7 helps you
Castle okay so which which one do you
guys think is more important cast
castline actually Bishop G7 not only
helps you
Castle but it stops me from castling
because this breaks the rules of chess
now if I could Castle Queen side that
move would be crushing and black would
be in a lot of trouble um but Bishop G7
prepares castles for you and also stops
castling for your opponent one of the
main three opening principles is
castling so that moves pretty good my
opponent did not play Bishop G7 and
instead played the move Bishop D7 after
Bishop G7 I would have played the move
Rook D1 and if he played Bishop D7 my
idea was to go Knight E4 Knight C5 and
try to Target this guy um there are
uh there's still some Advantage for
white but definitely better than what he
did um instead he played Bishop D7 and
now we have of course Castle's Queen
side which is an even better version of
Rook to D1 because we managed to get our
King safe at the same time okay so my
opponent in this position played the
move Queen to
C8 reason why he did that is because if
you plays Bishop to G7
now um I will play Knight to
E4 and um if you
Castle then uh White will play Knight C5
the bishop is attacked it's pinned you
can't move it um Black's most
interesting move is Pawn to A6 because
if I take on C6 this would be a pretty
horrible mistake black can save himself
with Bishop takes
C6 um wait actually that isn't even true
I just realized that I can take and take
and take uh never mind but my intention
during the game was to go here and D7 is
indefensible once once once again but
yeah or even Knight D7 but at any rate
uh my opponent played the move Queen C8
because he was afraid of the pin along
the D
line um I'm also going to tell you what
black wants to do so if black can move
again black wants to play the move Pawn
to A6 and if you move your Bishop then
he's solved a lot of his problems along
this diagonal and if you don't move your
Bishop he's going to take your Bishop so
my next move was designed purely against
his move Pawn
A6 White's
play I'm
sorry yeah these two pieces can't come
in contact with each other at the moment
I
think
all right twitch chat has got
it of course they're always too
fast oh yes oh sorry oh scratching okay
yeah fair
enough yeah this so um In fairness to
you that move I I checked the computer
afterwards that move wins I don't
actually know why I thought about it for
like two seconds during the game um if
you can justify it cool I I can't so I
played a different move but Rook D7 also
wins I played a simpler
move yeah like to me Rook takes D7 Queen
D7 Rook D1 and then Queen C8 yeah I see
the compensation but I don't exactly
know what my next move is whereas in the
game the move that I played I I sort of
knew what was going
on so remember black wants to play
A6 it's taking advantage of the fact
that black has no development he's
playing like morphe over
here
what do we
do yeah so if you if you move your other
Rook into the game then black will play
A6 kicking your Bishop away and
um yeah I mean if black manages to
consolidate like I play Bishop G7 in
Castle why is black worse right black
even has more control over the center
than you
do on account of having more
stuff yes
play
Knight the open Fook
is all right I I I hate you Devon all
right I will I will respond only to
chess notation from now
on I can't see the letters
and
okay maybe other people will piece
together what Devon said what Devon said
is correct but you
know he said Knight D5 that is what he
said Knight D5 um and the point is if
black plays the move Pawn A6 well what
do we have now what is the difference
yeah we have Knight to B6 and um after
Pawn takes obviously we don't take the
queen where he could take our Queen and
we would be lost we instead take his
rook and we have won in exchange um for
essentially no compensation now by the
way this is the best way for black to
play uh he did not do this because he
saw that in that position is winning for
white instead he played the move Bishop
to
G7 so once again White's play
and continue increasing your advantage I
mean you're you're winning but what do
you want to do here with
white I was very happy to play this
move Bishop G7 has the very very clear
intention of
castling actually let me give you um an
example if I play a move like Rook H1
which might seem smart and the black
castles some of you might say hey Julian
isn't that susceptible to a KN Fork I
would say yes
but if you play Knight takes E7 then he
plays Knight takes E7 and if you play
Bishop takes E7 he'll take you with the
bishop and after you Fork him the queen
is attacked on A4 so if I take you sorry
if I take you then you'll take me which
is no good right everything's the same
actually black would be slightly better
in this
position um
so the fact that the queen is on a whoa
oops I didn't mean to do that excuse me
all right we'll return back to this
position quickly I apologize I have
sequential
memory when was this game played I
played this sorry I played this game in
Chicago class uh maybe a month ago okay
when was the game
play
unclear sometime in the
1800s uh my opponent Play Bishop D7 1858
1858 okay there there you go Ben Simon
has all the knowledge Knight D5 Bishop
G7 and we are back all right White's
play and
win don't all shout out at
once twitch chat is
good they're considering good
moves not like the best moves but good
moves you
know
G5 Bishop G5 is an interesting idea I
considered it during the game but then
when I saw like the move that I
ultimately played I you know I didn't
want to play anything else Bishop G5
he'll play F6 and then there is
resistance right I'm not going to tell
you that Black's okay black is probably
not okay but you have a move that is
really strong and Bishop G5 doesn't
quite put the game
away after my next move black has has no
more
counterplay
Bishop C5 is better than Bishop
G5 but um so Bishop C5 has the right
idea um I'll give you a hint Bishop
takes E7 though is annoying but isn't as
good as if a different piece went to
E7 a different piece goes to E7 then
black might care a little
more
yeah Queen A3 with the idea of playing
Bishop takes C6 and queen takes E7
Checkmate and if you defend this way
after I take you well our Queen is no
longer on A4 by virtue of us moving it
to A3 so we win the game like like so
okay uh twitch chat suggested the move
Bishop B6 which is interesting because
um it'll come up in a second uh my
opponent played the move uh so I played
Queen A3 Queen d8 and then since this is
a beginner class I'll give you this move
for free Bishop B6 as suggested by
twitch chat and my opponent captured my
Bishop why did I do
that yeah Bishop B6 he just castles it's
the
issue again I'm not going to claim the
white isn't winning there
but this is obviously
cleaner take the yeah Queen takes uh
Queen takes Rook Queen takes rook and
then Knight C7 is a royal Fork we have
one material I play Knight takes A8 my
opponent played Bishop F5 I captured oh
sorry my apologies he did not do this he
played check first then he played Bishop
F5 I captured play Rook d8 took on h8
play Knight takes B6 my opponent
resigned because I have more Rooks than
he does and I have more pawns than he
does so
um yeah now the reason why my opponent
lost this game and again my opponent is
not a bad player this is a 2200 level
player he is he is a master right is he
played the move in in he played the
moves in the opening Queen C8 d8 C8
right he also played Knight from F6 to
G4 just wasting a ton of time in the
opening so he won a pawn but he had to
go knight from F6 to G4 to E5 to win
that pawn um just wasting a bunch of
time so in this position I have four
pieces out he has exactly one piece out
and then to um survive some tactics he
played Queen d8 C8 which was no good
right you do so even like strong players
can uh can forget to De develop their
pieces sometimes please develop your
pieces in the opening control the center
and Castle my opponent never castled and
lost the game all right I'm going to
show you another game that I
played all right my opponent in this
game is rated about
2050 um he he's quite yell and I think
he's he was 15 this game was played uh
in the Thanksgiving open I played the
move Knight F3 played D5 C4 C6
G3 so uh in this opening white is
prioritizing uh castling over
controlling the center it's fine it's a
different way of playing my opponent
played Bishop F5
uh I castled my opponent played E6 and I
took on D5 which is strictly speaking a
positional mistake but I had something
very Concrete in mind he played e takes
or sorry this isn't a positional mistake
but my next move is I play the move Pawn
to D4 which is a positional mistake
because I'm giving my opponent the E4
Square for free typically in these sorts
of positions you want to put your Pawn
on D3 to fight against these pieces um
D4 is okay my opponent played Knight D7
and then here I played Queen B3 with the
with a very specific
idea uh or so sorry sorry my my my
mistake Bishop D6 is what he played I
played Queen D3 and he played Queen
B6 all right it is white to play how can
we take advantage of
Black's
um uh Black's EXA exact move
order let's Force our opponent component
to violate the opening
principles in a
sense Sho is in chat sh hello shinoy yes
that is that is
correct see if anybody in our in-house
audience can figure it
out
best thing about that coffee is how cold
it
was so knight5 violates the opening
principles this is a suggestion in
twitch chat you are moving the same
piece twice um and blackw castle and
after castles um now more importantly
than even the violation of the opening
principles by putting you know moving
the same piece twice white is down the
E4 Square for no
reason but white can do something
Concrete in this exact position to
justify earlier
play take the bishop to so if you play
Bishop F4 then it's just like I mean
worst case scenario Queen takes Bishop
takes Pawn takes like is this end game
so
special I can't evaluate this as being
like anything special like immediately
so um maybe you can but I I don't know
black seems like he should be doing all
right here you have uh you have
better so this this would be like a
normal move right normal developing move
but we want I'll give you a hint we want
to stop black from castling we don't
want black to Castle because if you can
yeah Queen E3 check this is actually
kind of an awkward move to meet my
opponent in the game played the move
King f8 the reason why he did that is if
you play the move Bishop E7 which is
actually the best move after Knight C3
well you can't really Castle right
because your Bishop on E7 is hanging now
if you know this position
and you know that it's fine then you
find the move Queen d8 but black had to
move his Bishop from D6 to E7 and queen
from B6 to d8 um so we have forced our
opponent's pieces backwards right we're
forcing them to move their pieces
multiple times in the opening um so
practically speaking the position is uh
pretty good for white I think white has
good chances for an advantage my
opponent played King f8 um and actually
I learned this maneuver this queen B3 E3
maneuver from Grand Grandmaster alsan
moraba who is our current Grandmaster in
Residence in 2019 I got smashed by elhan
in the US Open and I also played King
f8 and Alshon against me played the move
Knight H4 so I decided to copy you know
Alshon and played Knight H4 against this
dude um in that game I played Bishop G6
and lost later U my opponent played the
move Bishop to E4 which is just a
mistake because I can take the bishop on
e4 after Knight takes I played F3
kicking him away and then Knight F5 so
we're attacking the
bishop okay so I have two threats one
threat is obvious the other threat is
maybe not so obvious so threat number
one is I want to take your Bishop right
threat number two is if you move your
queen to defend your Bishop in some way
I will take your Pawn check you and then
take your knight which is also a good
threat If you defend against both of
those things by playing Queen d8 such
that F6 is defended Ed I will play Queen
G5 attacking G7 you defend against that
I will play E4 and my Pawn on e4 is
taboo on account uh of the fact that the
queen is hanging on
d8 so this position is really really
really bad for
black um my opponent decided to play the
move sorry Knight to
E8 command
line um all right it is white to play
what would you guys like to do with
whites I don't really care about opening
principles you move the G Pawn instead
of developing naturally when you play G3
and Bishop G2 you're trying to Castle
you have violated no opening principles
I will stand by
that every Catalan player out there is
you know high-fiving
me
shoi suggests the move Knight C3 which
develops a
piece so it can't be too bad but black
has made a tactical
mistake oh man they're suggesting all
the things the suggestion in chat is
Knight D6 Knight D6 and then Queen E5
Knight E8 Bishop H6 the point being if
they take then you take I like the
creativity but uh I don't got to do
anything can probably just like develop
my piece right Knight Knight
D7 and actually probably black WIS here
because you need to move your queen and
once you move your queen I can finally
take your
Bishop but
um we'll say these these pieces are
lined up poorly this is a bad
relationship right D6 and f8 now that's
fine as long as the piece that's on D6
can move diagonally so I took his bishop
and then I exploited the fact that as
Kane and Knight were lined up on the
same
diagonal yeah Queen A3 so Queen A3 the
Knight is attacked on D6 and there's not
really a convenient way to defend it my
opponent decided to go Pawn hunting with
Queen D4 he should not have done that he
should have just defended with K E7
which is really awkward right you don't
want your cane in the center in the
opening Queen takes D4 what would you
guys like to do with
white yes lock with the bishop yep
Bishop F sorry Bishop E3 so if our
opponent plays the move Queen E5 then we
win immediately if our opponent goes to
any other Square we will take the Knight
our Bishop is defended by our Queen so
the queen must go to F6 what would you
like to do
here yep can we use the bishop to attack
the Knight yep Bishop F4 oh sorry um so
Bishop C5 is worse because after King E7
um your Bishop is subject to attack so
if I play Knight D7 then I will gain a
Tempo on your Bishop whereas my Bishop
on F4 is kind of safe from developing
moves my opponent played King E7 and
this is a principle that is true
throughout all of all of middle games
and when there are lots of pieces on the
board not just the opening but when your
opponent's keing is in the center you
should try to open the center because
the goal of game of the you know the
goal of Chess is Checkmate and it's more
more likely you'll Checkmate them if the
center is open so what would you guys
like to do here with
white uh Knight
where3 yeah Knight C3 is not a bad move
by any means but you do have something
that is maybe slightly more
aggressive yeah throw down the center
with the pawn can we throw down in the
center with the pawn was the suggestion
by Devon I only respond to chess
notation from you from now
on yes we can indeed throw down on e4 by
playing the move Pawn to
E4 uh E4 makes a threat our threat is
Pawn to E5 because you know in a turn
based game where you're only allowed to
make one move per turn if I attack two
different things that's that's annoying
right it's going to be hard to deal with
you know both your queen and your Knight
hanging um if you take my Pawn
what what would you like to do
here you just shrug at me that's what
you do just
shrug you want to take back taking back
is fine uh taking back threatens the
move Pawn E5 uh actually the this was
not my intention because I didn't you
know I don't want to calculate any
checks it's too much work you know maybe
you went here not me though I want to do
zero calculation
yeah so when your opponent's Knights are
like double pinned morphe style you
should attack their their Knight right
yeah so Rook here sorry Rook to D1 uh
Rook d8 is uh the only move that can
possibly save the Knight now what would
you like to do with
white yeah now now Pawn takes is is far
more reasonable um I got to admit my
that was wasn't my intention my
intention was to go Knight C3 developing
a piece which also threatens Knight
captures E4 or if you would like after
Pawn takes just Knight E4 attacking the
queen and the Knight and I like this one
a little more because we developed our
pieces while attacking your move is fine
because you can justify it with very
concrete analysis that concrete analysis
being Knight D7 E5 takes and then Rook
E1 all right Devon all right
Devon but that's not what I wanted to do
um so my opponent didn't do that in said
he played shck um I moved my king to the
corner intuitively because I didn't want
him to I I want him to be as safe as
possible um my opponent played the move
Pawn takes
E4 because or sorry that's not true he
played the move Pawn to C5 if he played
Pawn T takes E4 then Knight C3 obviously
wins immediately so he played Pawn to
C5 all right this game did not last too
much longer see if you can play like me
the rest of the game
which and you
know it's rare that playing like me is
anonymous with playing well but that
happened to be the case for this
game
uh so just to respond to Twitch chat in
that variation after e E4 Knight
D7 E5 Knight E5 Rook E1 Knight C4 was
not legal because my queen was pinning
your knight to the king so no that was
not a
defense Bishop takes D5 and Knight C3
threatening Knight B5 for so you mean
Bishop takes
D6 um that is not what I did I played a
very similar idea with the same sorry
the same idea in mind um Bishop D6 I
didn't want to do because this piece is
better than that piece like I am tagging
his Knight on D6 right and I really
don't want to take like this
is these two pieces this this piece has
the better relationship right I can
trade this bishop for this Knight this
Knight cannot trade for this bishop
which means inherently this bishop is
better than that Knight at least at the
moment so I am unwilling to do that but
I agree that this idea of takes and
Knight C3 is powerful because there's
Knight B5 and White's probably winning
here too but instead I played it through
a different move order which means I
played what move
here Knight Knight C3 which I I I like
because it develops the last piece and
we have created a large threat Bishop
captures D6 King takes D6 and Knight B5
is our Royal fork okay my opponent
played the move Knight C4 in the game I
played the move Queen to B3 my opponent
play Knight to
B6 okay Whit's play what would you like
to do with
whites what is the piece that's doing
the least amount of
work oh somebody sorry I should answer
that question question somebody asked
does Queen B4 defend after Knight to C3
the answer is no because Knight takes D
D5 attacks B4 and
E7 so Knight C4 Queen B3 Knight B6 and
now you have to ask yourself the
question what piece in White's position
is doing the least amount of
work and twitch chat has found the move
after that question was
asked The Rook the other Rook there are
two other Rooks depending upon your
perspective
sare yeah a rook A1 yeah so where would
you like to put that
Rook yep Rook a D1 and
um it is uh there there are no there's
not really a convenient Square for his
Queen to go to um if he plays Queen to
F6 which I thought he might do he played
Queen B4 in the game uh I'll make that
the main line uh if he plays the move
Queen to F6 my intention was to go
Knight D5 and then Queen takes B7 which
attacks his rook and his king and you
also don't really have a way to defend
like if you go Knight D7 Rook takes D5 I
have threat number one which is hard to
stop in the first place I have threat
number two which is also hard to stop
and if you try to defend against
everything well Rook e five is
inconvenient to say the
least right um instead I mean every
square has a tactical problem he uh if
you play Queen C4 the Knight takes D5
and if you take me back I I take your
queen amongst other things so he decided
to play Queen B4 how would you guys like
to finish this game with
whites
yep Knight takes D5 just just as simple
as that takes and how would you like to
recapture yeah now here the only move
that even pretends to defend is Knight
C6 which is what he played and my my
opponent resigned in two
mys some finishing touches on this
game you could play a move like Queen D7
and then King f8 but that's obviously
like you know like the game goes on
and the game shouldn't go
on black has committed too many
sins Bishop G5 has been suggested in
chat but after Pawn to F6 um at least to
me I don't see like anything super clean
like Queen D6 sure nobody's going to
argue with you that this position is
better you know better for white but why
is it so over my opponent resigned in
two
moves
Queen D6 Queen D7 has been suggested but
once again I mean yeah obviously white
is better probably objectively winning
like computer winning here but the game
the game will keep going you can give me
more checks but you can't win with a
Queen by you know by itself so it's not
super clear how you win
here
D2 if you play Rook D2 then black
actually might survive after Rook to d8
right if black can coordinate
technically Black's not down anything
right okay I mean realistically white
should still be winning there after
Bishop D6
but the position has
improved
yeah so him taking the pawn on B2 I
don't think is super realistic so he's
going to stay in touch with his Pawn on
C5 um yeah I mean I'm sure this move
wins but you just you just have
something that's way way cleaner
bishop6 yeah Bishop D6 so if Ken F6 then
Queen F5 is Checkmate so if King
E8 Bishop takes yeah and he resigned
here on account of you having two
threats Bishop takes B uh C sorry Bishop
takes B4 if only I knew my chess
coordinates and queen D7 is also
checkmat um now why did this happen oh
Elan is uh has has come in the room uh I
played your line that you played against
me which one yeah why did you play yeah
yeah Queen B3 yeah so Alshon smashed me
in 2019 so I decided to smash some 2,000
later uh
want uh yeah so obviously this opening
is a lot more sophisticated than the
other openings that we looked at before
I mean morphe's game is not super
theoretically interesting in my second
game uh my opponent uh played pretty
badly early on um all of this is like
kind of okay but the big idea of Queen
E3 is you disrupt your opponents
developments you force him to play a
couple of you know negative opening
principles right like you want to Castle
in the opening and King f8 is uh is not
a good move because you can't Castle
anymore which I also played against you
was b b no I played uh it was the other
way I play King f8 later yeah Bish I had
Knight D7 Queen E3 Bishop E7 then King
f8 yeah but
um but yeah kef uh ke f8 is bad because
in the opening you want to Castle can't
Castle anymore so white already has some
kind of Advantage Knight H4 and Bishop
E4 is bad because after I take the F5
square is is weak and you will notice
that my opponent's Knight moved a lot
this game so my opponent played uh
played Knight to F6 Knight to E4 Knight
back to F6 Knight to
D6 then
later then later he goes Knight C4 then
Knight B6 and I managed to trade off my
knight that moved twice for his Knight
that moved a thousand times so probably
that's not that's not ideal and
no Bishop C5 and my opponent resigned he
did not move these Rooks his King ended
up back back where it came from this
queen is misplaced and yeah black
essentially only has one useful
developed piece so once again uh please
I I beg you develop your develop your
pieces and chest control the center and
Castle morphe uh morphy's opponents got
smashed back in the day because they
didn't castle and uh um even even some
very strong players that I've played
recently I mean I played a master who
lost essentially for the same reason he
didn't castle and this this player is
like a 15-year-old expert so he's you
know also pretty good um and he lost the
game because he just did not develop any
of his pieces um do any of you have any
questions before I hand it off to
Alshon no okay well thank you for
attending my class um on opening
principles thank
[Music]
you